welcome to this video playing I and I
why something okay yeah last game I did
not upload huh why did i do that i had a
huge connection problem right in the
middle of the game i lost like three
minutes and I yeah it was kind of a not
nothing happening position and then I
lost on time and yeah it was a pretty
much a complete game so I just didn't
upload it so let's go here in this game
okay yeah that combination of Queen 23
and Bishop g5 sometimes played but not
particularly dangerous let's see what
happens with their five Queen f6 it's
interesting it's not a totally bad
opening for for white but it's nothing
to be very afraid of let's see what he's
doing Bishop d3 gentlemen I can just
take there's nothing particularly wrong
with it okay and also any five as
possible I have a pretty good play in
the center threatening me for for the
moment to fork him so we have to react
in the center and it's not like white
has all the time in the world to Castle
double on the edge file and so on yeah
my king and this age six g5 thing is
kind of weak but it's not like he can
exploit it quickly yeah that's
interesting now I can play too
interesting moves I can play g4 or just
f1 a good g-form he will have to give me
the default square let's do that I mean
I prayed it pretty quickly but it looks
like an interesting IDM getting the
night to deform on that big week nurser
this big weekend square and only then
play a form so leads to an active
an active looking position so let's do
this and then F for next yeah it doesn't
have great squares there what he has to
CS ideas of putting 9 p-3 it's not a
problem or hmm ok yeah I take I take the
rook I mean let's take that and she
cannot even recapture because some yes
so but that's also not not going to work
very lightly at least if I check f5 I
had let's take that first ask questions
later I one day I Quincy for as of
course in the mix hmm interesting do I
just cover that like when g5 and move
like that if it takes a one yeah that's
probably a good idea if it takes a one
he's completely misplaced so I have this
this temple with afore he cannot take
rook e8 as a deadly pin and i will tell
i can check f5 next or maybe III is also
an interesting move depends a bit on way
it's going
no bad looks good maybe rook d8 was even
stronger but maybe even stronger just
took a d8 attacking that Bishop
maybe that was stronger so what now III
or is that is that bonkers no probably
not huh looks kind of dangerous maybe
has to Castle
when I can just take a five with the
rook the only thing that's clearly a
check clearly happening is my king is
still some wood week so there's always
necessity for for some caution you
cannot just expect to win automatically
easily with this kind of this kind of
King position but this is good I think
okay but if I go I mean something on the
e-file looks very dangerous I can look
at you one I rook e8 I'm sorry now let's
do that hiroki one that should be
sufficient
this should be true i can just take
yeah no white resigns let's see Jim it
doesn't look too great iam but I don't
really remember the precise um yeah how
does this play theoretically speaking I
know that this is close to being a known
position I have it invite in my book but
i'm not sure but this is definitely okay
for black after g4 also FYI for us also
not a bad idea for for this taking and
then plant the night on default it some
more gas strategically focused and way
to play it but this looks very dangerous
already the engine wants to play 92 94
and to Queen c3 and gives black a slight
advantage after Queen g5 yeah that's
also an interesting idea I was thinking
about I mean I thought aquella i thought
either f4 or queen g5 both look quite
good if white castles long i can take
care that's pretty nice black winter
there's no no move here because thats
that's a very big IDM yeah after that 94
he already has a big problem if he goes
on the third-ranked i'm taking here and
i'm also threatening here so winds also
so he had to go there actually already
yeah which means the whole thing is just
lost yeah now i went Queen g5 which was
not bad group the eight is better but I
like that move its ok but he rook da
this is even a bit stronger than you for
it just gets a look into the game
quicker and why it has no decent reply
can do this something like
and it's a very simple win because the
pieces are so active the shoe p.m. and
III okay that's also winning but check
other things were a bit bit bit quicker
Andrew creator there was an opening an
opening disaster on the whole the whole
line is pretty much not very promising
for white but it is not terribly bad he
just has to after you fight I think
probably played differently or or maybe
change something earlier it doesn't feel
very threatening here for black due to
that e4 idea I don't really know what
why it is supposed to do I mean you can
take take and avoid the movie for play
something like that but that's never
going to be a huge huge problem for
black I mean I'm developing like this
and i can go rook to the eighth night
sorry 95 those kind of ideas can never
be a real problem for black okay well
thanks for watching